es ist ja fakt das leben jenseits von
corona geht tatsächlich irgendwie weiter
so zum beispiel auch der kampf um den
cdu vorsitz ja momentan ein fight
zwischen 3 gut abgaben den jungs aus
nordrhein westfalen anfang dezember beim
cdu-parteitag fällt die entscheidung
hoch spannende sache märz laschet und
der eine gutaussehende den man irgendwie
noch von früher kennt vielleicht doch
wer von denen wird von ein paar monate
fast kanzlerkandidat bevor dann im märz
markus hinker übernehmen könnte sei nur
eine von vielen theorien gut von den
dreien hier am besten vernetzt ist
natürlich eindeutig armin laschet
legendärer strippenzieher extrem knuffig
niedlich und er hat den perfekten
partner mit dem jungen konservativen
sparen bildet der armin das dynamische
duo seit batman und robin
[Musik]
cool oder jetzt die schlechte nachricht
lasches umfrageergebnisse in der
bevölkerung sind leider ja nicht so gut
deswegen melden sich jetzt schon die
ersten cdu hinterbänkler und sagen idee
könnte nicht einfach sparen vorsitzender
werden und laschet macht irgendwas
anderes
[Musik]
ist nur ein brainstorm aus den tiefen
der cdu-basis am ende stimmt die cdu
traditionell so ab wie man es ihr sagt
unterstützt wird laut stadt angeblich
von der frauen union
davon kann einen friedlichen märz
natürlich nur träumen
der mann von dem es heißt man hätte ihm
ideologisch irgendwann in den 90ern
eingefroren 26 prozent der wählerinnen
wollen sie nur als parteichef haben sie
ein frauenproblem frau hasse ich habe
auch sehr viele unterstützung gerade bei
den frauen bekommen wenn ich meine post
richtig lese dann sind das zur hälfte
mindestens zur hälfte frauen die mir
schreiben auch ganz junge frau vor allem
für haushalt vor allem blutjunge dinger
schreiben wir bei tik tok
kann ja sein ist ja möglich und dann ist
da natürlich noch der sogenannte
underdog kandidatin nummer drei unser
heutiger studio gast
was kann man über norbert röttgen sagen
es lange im geschäft kennt sich mit
außenpolitik aus und hat in jedem fall
enorme nehmerqualitäten und design
beratungsresistent sie seien bis zum
autismus irgendwie nicht zugänglich da
war von realitätsverlust die rede also
eigentlich also eigentlich möchte ich
jetzt nach hause gehen und mich langsam
in den schlaf weinen später gern jetzt
ist erstmal bei uns in der heute schon
herzlich willkommen norbert röttgen
halo ist sie schön dass sie da sind ich
habe gelesen sie haben sich ein
richtiges tv duell im guten alten
fernsehen gewünscht mit allen dreien da
haken die anderen beiden wollten nicht
warum nicht und wer es hier nicht leer
gewesen
also ist es nicht ganz so dass es mir
gewünscht habe sondern wir wurden
eingeladen
ich muss allerdings sagen von der ard
und ich fand es eine gute sache und ich
fand es eigentlich selbstverständliche
sache denn debatte gehört ja zur
demokratie gehört zur innerparteilichen
demokratie
und ich glaube dass auf dem nächsten cdu
vorsitzende noch ganz andere diskutanten
zu kommen als die eigenen parteifreunde
und das ist ja auch keine interne
angelegenheit sondern ich glaube wer
neuer cdu vorsitzende wird dafür
interessiert sich ganz europa und darum
glaube ich muss man miteinander
diskutieren ich glaube auch die cdu
hätte davon nur gewonnen aber sie sehen
ist ich habe die einladung angenommen
aber ich glaube es kommt nicht dazu ja
wir haben das muss ich den zuschauer und
sagen natürlich auch für diese sendung
die beiden rivalen eingeladen die haben
beide abgesagt aus termingründen glaube
laschet musste nochmal zum papst und
märz hat einen ölwechsel an der
schaeffler ich weiß nicht jetzt ist es
ja so das fand ich sehr spannend sie
haben gesagt ich möchte cdu-chef werden
es erklärt auch ihre bewerbung aber ich
muss nicht unbedingt kanzler werden ich
habe in einem interview sogar gelesen
sie können sich markus söder als kanzler
vorstellen heißt das habe ich sie
richtig verstanden
sie werden zum ersten mal bereit
deutschland an einen bayern auszuliefern
beziehungsweise franken was es nicht
viel besser macht es sich dabei ist das
allerdings ein ganz gewaltiger
unterschied also ich habe zuerst
zunächst gesagt ich kandidiere für das
amt des cdu vorsitzenden und dieses amt
hat einen eigenen anspruch ist eine
eigene große aufgabe denn die cdu ist
erneuerungsbedürftig wir sind auch als
partei auf das was uns auf uns zu kommt
in den nächsten jahren in diesem
jahrzehnt noch nicht vorbereiteten darum
ist es eine eigene aufgabe und nicht
sozusagen das mittel zum zweck für ein
anderes amt das erst mal mein
selbstverständnis davon allerdings ist
mein selbstverständnis auch dass der
cdu-vorsitzende sich das kanzleramt
zutrauen muss und das ist glaube ich
schon bei söder und ist auch wollen
mussten ja der ist aber nicht der cdu
vorsitzende
und das ist auch bei mir so diesen
anspruch habe ich bin aber auch der
meinung das ist das wichtigste ist dass
wir die bundestagswahl gewinnen könntest
du ja noch bis zu diesem showdown im
dezember irgend so eine art team lösung
geben auf die man sich verständigt das
war ja die hoffnung zum beispiel frau
von und frau kramp karrenbauer dass man
sagt pass auf machen das jetzt auch im
hinterzimmer laschet kanzler röttgen
außenminister märz weil sie nicht
familie und frauen ist das völlig
ausgeschlossen dass man sich vorher noch
irgendwie auf eine gemeinsame lösung ein
also dieses einigen ist natürlich
irgendwie immer auch etwas was man
möchte vielleicht aber ich bin nicht ich
bin angetreten weil ich etwas anderes
für wichtiger halte ich bin der meinung
das ist nicht nur und vor allem um eine
personalfrage geht sondern das was mich
antreibt ist das unser land darüber dass
unsere partei aber unser land vor
dramatischen veränderungen steht und auf
die sind wir noch nicht vorbereitet wir
hinken in der digitalisierung peinlich
skandalös zurück 10 20 jahre in manchen
bereichen
sie haben als erste ihren hut in den
ring geworfen und haben direkt danach
gesagt ich werde in jedem fall dafür
sorgen dass dann eine frau das amt der
generalsekretärin bekommt dazu habe ich
seitdem nichts mehr gehört haben sie in
der zwischenzeit eine frau kennengelernt
ich habe sogar viele frauen kennen
gelernt und bin auch für dieses amt
nicht mehr auf der suche
sie haben jemanden gefunden und werde
das zu gegebener zeit ist auch eine
frage des zeitpunktes gibt ein besseres
forum als das jahr wird gefragt dass da
haben sie eigentlich natürlich recht das
habe ich mir jetzt nur vorher gar nicht
überlegt ja so spontan kann ich jetzt
auch wieder jetzt entstehen natürlich
der verdacht dass sie doch noch keine
haben wenn sie das nicht sagen wollen
wer sich als reiner erpresser sind oder
ein ganz großer helfer helfen sie uns
doch beim eingegrenzt sagen wir zahlen
schon viele person haarfarbe alter kommt
sie aus dem osten wenigstens der name
also dass wir mit irgendwas aber es ist
eine ganz überzeugende frau die
politische erfahrung hat und
gleichzeitig für erneuerungen und
innovation steht das wird dann auf dem
parteitag miteinander nicht auf den
palästen also deutlich vor dem parteitag
aber irgendwie noch nicht heute aber ist
wieder im mai bilder oder ladens nein
zugesichert okay na gut sie sind ja
außenpolitik experte hat man eben auch
gehört was ich befürchte wenn ich ihnen
das sagen daher könnten im laufe dieses
wettkampfs ein marken problem bekommen
ja weil die anderen so klar definiert
sind als makler im märz steht natürlich
für den bruch mit der ära merkel
laschet steht für kontinuität was das
angeht stehen sie natürlich ein bisschen
entschuldigung für das gewisse nichts
müssten sie nicht mehr polarisieren
insgesamt zurück
also ich bin sie das so sagen werde ich
noch mal drüber nach der ich glaube aber
nicht zu wissen glaube ich dann wieder
wendler aber sie müssen eben die
polarisiert nein ich glaube ich glaube
dass ich mein thema ist dass wir uns für
die zukunft vorbereiten müssen die
anderen bereiten sich auch nicht für die
vergangenheit vor also ja das war nicht
sehr wohl aber jetzt will ich auch den
anderen nicht unterstellen aber ich
mache jedenfalls aussagen dazu wie die
zukunft aussieht was auf uns zukommt in
welchen umbrüchen wir sind das die
gewissheiten wegbrechen dass unsere
partei nicht so bleiben kann wie wir
sind wir können keiner wesentlichen der
renommierte band einen seien die
digitalisierung ansprechen es gibt ja
keinen auch nicht unter ihren
mitbewerbern der sache digitalisierung
brauchen wir nicht das haben sie ja
nicht exklusiv also das ist ja also
sagen wir brauchen wir brauchen aber
einen wir brauchen ein ziel eine
ambition deutschland digital 2015 als
einen gesamtgesellschaftlichen pactum um
das zu beschleunigen einen
modernisierungsschub jetzt ist ja in der
politik volkstümlichkeit wirklich nicht
das wichtigste aber sie befinden sich im
wahlkampf und da muss man jetzt
zumindest volkstümlichkeit glaubhaft
simulieren können
der goldstandard war immer gerhard
schröder der aus als wenn er mit
bratwurst und bier auf die welt gekommen
wäre wenn sie so was im netz posten oder
wenn so was von ihnen auftrag wie dieses
bild auf dem aus dem oktober
ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist nur mein
gefühl ich finde sich fremdeln irgendwie
ich will nicht sagen sie haben noch nie
eine bierflasche gehalten irgendwie
komisch aussah weiß ich nicht mehr hat
sie jedenfalls nicht jedenfalls beides
gut geschmeckt ja seine original
thüringer bratwurst mit einem bier nach
einer veranstaltung wurde gekämpft haben
in thüringen in wutha farnroda und
anschließend haben wir zusammen
gestanden und wurst gegessen und bier
getrunken hat geschmeckt so entstand und
dann ganz gut und so entstand das foto
was glauben sie wird dieser parteitag im
dezember stichwort zweite welle und
corona überhaupt stattfinden können der
parteitag wird völlig anders werden als
jeder zuvor aber er wird ein
schutzkonzept haben es gibt einen plan b
um eben auch zu zeigen und zu
verwirklichen das das wichtigste
stattfindet nämlich politik demokratie
und parteileben ich bin gespannt aber
drücken vielen daran gesehen
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten
einfach anklicken macht's gut
los los du scheiße fährt haye